Major political news!
CBS is reporting that Joe Biden's dog, Major,
will get his very own indoguration ceremony this Sunday!
Look at them!
And Major is also making hound history next week
becoming the first rescue pup to set paw in the White House.
The Delaware Humane Society is hosting
the virtual dog party,
which you can attend by donating 10 bucks
to help out other sweet little pups find
their forever homes.
And we should add that a cat is said
to be joining the White House as well.
I have heard that.
Yes, we will stay on top of these details
and bring them to you as they develop.
I know, it's absolutely true.
Douglas, my rescue dog is somewhere (whistles).
Over there!
Dougie, come on over here!
Speaking of doggies, Ross, we never want this show to end.
So we thought that every day we could leave you
with something to carry with you.
So without further ado, please meet the Doggy Bag.
(whimsical music)
(dog barking)
Oh!
That's right.
I like that!
And today's little tip to go is
the Paricon Snowball Maker.
I have to tell you, this is no joke.
This has changed my life.
My girls absolutely love it.
In fact, watch here's us slinging snowballs in Central Park.
Thank you.
We're going to build these snowballs and they all (mumbles).
Now watch out.
Run!
(children laughing)
Turn around!
I mean--
That is so cute!
Those are the moments!
We went to the park this weekend, Ross,
we do the group of friends,
socially distance, masks, the whole nine.
We went for a walk and Dougie was there, your little dog,
And you forgot a doggy bag for a pickup--
That's right!
A different kind of doggy bag.
And this is my favorite story if I can tell it,
but we were like, "What are we going to do?
"The doggie went!"
And you went up to a lady--
Well, Brandon, who's like head of our integrations,
to give me the idea,
I was like, "I see a bag over there in the corner,
"I'm sure it's clean."
But she goes up to this woman like,
"Excuse me, do you have an extra doggy bag?"
And the woman was so nice by the way, Drew covered in a mask
and a hat, she looks like this.
And the woman, they have this nice conversation,
she has no idea Drew Barrymore just asked her
for a doggy bag for her dog.
She had no idea it was you!
Yeah and she was just so nice
because leaving poop in the park is like,
I mean, it's just the worst.
I mean, you, it is just blasphemy!
So to that strange lady, thanks for the bag!
Thank you!
And to you guys at home,
if you and your friends, loved one, kids,
anybody wants to make a snowball.
That density is perfect.
The throwage makes them perfect.
The spread out when it has contact.
This is literally, you will never look
at snowballs the same way again
and you'll never want to be without it.
So that's today's doggy bag.
Thank you for watching.
(upbeat music)